SURE HE WILL BE ON THE
BEST SELLER LIST SOON.
>> Will: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "FOX NEWS PRIMETIME,"
I AM WILL CAIN.
I BEGIN THIS WEEK OFF SHOWING
YOU THE HEARTBREAKING VIDEOS,
ONE IN PARTICULAR OF AN OFFICER
RESIGNING OVER VACCINE MANDATES.
AND I SAID, IT WOULDN'T BE THE
LAST TIME WE SEE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, AND I MEAN THIS
UNFORTUNATELY, I WAS RIGHT.
LET'S CHECK IN FROM
COAST-TO-COAST.
FIRST RIGHT HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY, WHERE
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO VACCINE
MANDATE IS TRAMPLING ON THE
RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS OF
NEW YORK'S FINEST.
>> IT'S A MANDATE NOW FOR ALL
CITY AGENCIES, ALL CITY WORKERS,
IT'S TIME FOR EVERYONE TO GET
VACCINATED.
IF YOU CHOOSE NOT TO, YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO GO ON UNPAID LEAVE.
WE WILL WORK WITH YOUR UNION TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENS NEXT,
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE ARE
NOT GOING TO PAY PEOPLE UNLESS
THEY ARE VACCINATED.
>> Will: HE WON'T GET FIRED,
YOU JUST WON'T GET PAID.
TELLING THE CITY'S COPS, DO WHAT
I SAY OR GO HOME, BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT ABOUT SCIENCE OR SAFETY,
IF THAT WAS THE CASE, HE WOULD
NOT BE SAYING GOODBYE TO THE
THIN BLUE LINE THAT STANDS IN
THE WAY OF ITS CITIZENS IN THE
ALREADY SPIKING MURDER RATE IN
THE CITY.
NO, IT'S ABOUT CONTROL.
THESE OFFICERS ALREADY PATROLLED
THE STREETS DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THIS PANDEMIC WHEN CASES WERE
NEARLY TRIPLE WHAT THEY ARE NOW.
AND BEFORE WE EVEN HAD A
VACCINE, BUT NOW SUDDENLY THINGS
ARE MORE DANGEROUS.
SUDDENLY THE NYPD CAN'T DO THEIR
JOB IF THEY DON'T TAKE THE SHOT,
WHAT KIND OF SENSE DOES THAT
MAKE?
AND THE AUTHORITARIAN OVERREACH
IS NOT UNIQUE TO NEW YORK,
POLICE OFFICERS ARE BEING FORCED
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR JOB AND
THE JOB, LET'S TRAVEL WEST, IN
CHICAGO, A CITY TORN APART BY
VIOLENCE, 2600 SHOOTINGS JUST
THIS YEAR.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT NOT ONLY
WHAT THEY HAVE, BUT GO ADD NEW
ONES.
INSTEAD, MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
SAID TO WITH THE SAFETY OF HER
CITY'S RESIDENTS.
SHE JUST NEEDS AND WANTS
CONTROL.
WILLING TO LOSE THOUSANDS OF
OFFICERS OVER HER FAX MANDATE.
2,000 OFFICERS HAD YET TO LOAD
THEIR VACCINE OR TESTING STATUS
ON UP PORTAL AND SO FAR 21
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN STRIPPED OF
THEIR POLICE POWERS AND SENT
HOME WITHOUT PAY ACCORDING TO
ABC.
SO CHICAGO HAS DECIDED,
COMPLIANCE, MORE IMPORTANT THAN
SAFETY.
BECAUSE AGAIN, THE LEFT JUST
WANTS TO GET THEIR WAY.
THEY WANT CONTROL, AND THEY ARE
WILLING TO DEHUMANIZE,
DEHUMANIZE THOSE THAT DON'T
FOLLOW THE ORDERS THAT REACH
THAT GOAL.
IT TO THEM THE UNVACCINATED ARE
THE ENEMY WHO SHOULD NEVER BE
ASSOCIATED WITH, THEY HAVE SAID
IT IN THEIR OWN WORDS, LOOK AT
HOW CNN SO-CALLED MENTAL MEDICAL
EXPERT TO LIANA LYNN
CHARACTERIZED IT THIS PAST
SUMMER.
>> WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO AT
THIS POINT IS MAKE VACCINATION
THE EASY CHOICE, AND IT NEEDS TO
BE HARD FOR PEOPLE TO REMAIN
UNVACCINATED.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES LIFE
HARDER, LOSING YOUR JOB, SO THE
LEFT IS SUCCEEDING.
THEY HAVE MADE LIFE INCREDIBLY
HARD, DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE WHO
KEEP US SAFE, MAKE IT HARD FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD STAND IN THE WAY
OF US AND VIOLENCE, LET'S GO
FURTHER WEST IN SEATTLE WHERE
DOZENS OF COPS AND FIREFIGHTERS
WERE FORCED OUT OVER THAT CITY'S
MANDATE.
THESE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN STOOD
UP AND MARKED ON CITY HALL TO
DROP OFF THEIR BOOTS IN SYMBOLIC
PROTEST, BECAUSE OF SEATTLE
WON'T PROTECT THEIR FREEDOMS,
WHY SHOULD THEY RISK THEIR LIVES
TO PROTECT IT.
THE CITY HAD JUST HAD A SUMMER
OF LOVE, OR SO IT WAS CALLED,
AND LOOKS LIKE IT IS ABOUT TO
ENTER THE WINTER OF DANGER AND
VIOLENCE APPEARED AT THE END OF
THE DAY YOU NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES ARE BEING TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN OVER VACCINE THAT DIDN'T
EXIST 24 MONTHS AGO, PLUS TO
HELP MAKE LIFE HARDER, THESE
FIRST RESPONDERS JUST WANT TO
KEEP THE LIVES THEY ALREADY HAD,
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY ARE WE WHEN
POLICE OFFICERS ARE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE, SCRATCH THAT, THEY ARE
TARGETS IN A FIGHT OVER A
VACCINE LIKE THIS, WASHINGTON
STATE POLICE SERGEANT.
>> MY PERSONAL CHOICE TO TAKE A
MORAL STANCE AGAINST IT FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM AND PERSONAL
CHOICE.
I WILL BE SENDING OUT OF SERVICE
FOR THE LAST TIME TODAY AFTER
NEARLY 17 YEARS OF SERVING THE
CITIZENS IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON, IT HAS BEEN MY HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE TO WORK ALONGSIDE
OF YOU.
WE KNOW IN THIS DISTRICT ON THE
19TH THERE WILL BE 51 OF THE 75
TROOPERS AVAILABLE, AND ONLY
SEVEN OF THE 11 SERGEANTS.
>> HARDWORKING, DETERMINED, AND
CARING INDIVIDUAL, I AM HONORED
TO HAVE BEEN YOUR DISPATCHER,
BUT MOSTLY PROUD TO BE YOUR
WIFE, OUR FUTURE IS BRIGHT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
>> AND THANK YOU FOR YEARS AND
FOR BEING BY MY SIDE.
>> Will: NOT JUST POLICE
FORCES, BUT FAMILIES, 17 YEARS
PATROLLING THE STREETS AND
KEEPING A COMMUNITY SAFER NOW
GONE AND FOR WHAT?
LUNACY.
WE TOSSED AROUND WORDS, WORDS,
VACCINATED, UNVACCINATED, AND
STATS, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE HERE, YOU KNOW IT, I WILL
TAKE YOU UP ON THAT, LET'S JUST
TALK ABOUT STATS FOR ONE MOMENT,
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT, THEIR
MANDATE WENT INTO EFFECT ON
MONDAY, 3% OF THE WORKFORCE HAS
QUIT OR BEEN FIRED.
ANOTHER 3% HAVE BEEN REASSIGNED,
ANOTHER 4.6 PERCENT IS CURRENTLY
IN THE STATE OF FLUX, SO ADD
THAT UP AND YOU GET OVER 10% OF
PRISON GUARDS, FIREMEN,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AFFECTED BY
THE DEHUMANIZATION.
AND THAT'S JUST IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON.
LET'S TAKE A QUICK TRIP BACK
EAST AND GO TO NEW YORK WHERE
"AMONG POLICE 30 PERCENT ARE
STILL NOT VACCINATED" AND AMONG
NEW YORK'S BRAVEST "NEARLY 45%
OF FDNY FIREFIGHTERS ARE
UNVACCINATED."
YOU SEE THE COST OF THESE
MANDATES TO HER SAFETY, TO OUR
CITIES, TO US, TO PRINCIPLED ME